[Music]
what's up Wolfgang it's time to get
started with today's video with The
Avengers infinity war coming out in just
10 days I thought I would go over the
Infinity Gauntlet comic saga because
this is where Avengers infinity war
stems from I've been getting a lot of
questions about who I think will die in
Avengers infinity war and who actually
died in Infinity Gauntlet so today I'll
be going over who dies in Infinity
Gauntlet also be sure to hit that
subscribe button and doesn't take a PhD
to figure it out
[Music]
[Music]
so to start off I'd like to talk about
the heroes that died who aren't going to
be in a vendor's infinity war I don't
want to spend too much time on them
because I want to spend most of my focus
on today's video about the Avengers so
Doctor Strange works his mystic arts and
sends a bunch of heroes to fight Thanos
in mid-space from here Theano starts
picking them off one by one first ago
our Submariner and she-hulk and they
died by space fungi that Thanos puts on
them
Thanos thing kills Wolverine by turning
his bones into rubber he thing kills
Cyclops by suffocating him cloak tries
to capture Thanos inside of his cloak
and keep him there but then Thanos blows
him up he turns Nova into toy blocks or
essentially Legos and he blows up quasar
by shooting energy beams from his eyes
are you starting to understand just how
powerful Santos is so now I'll start
with the heroes that we'll see in
Avengers infinity war in Avengers 4
first to go is the lovely Wanda aka The
Scarlet Witch The Scarlet Witch and
Cyclops attacked Thanos at the same time
unfortunately for the Scarlet Witch
Thanos turns his sides towards her first
he then uses her own hex powers against
her and she dies instantly being blown
up next to die is vision who tries to
sneak up and trick Thanos but Thanos
doesn't fall for it not falling for the
trick Thanos punches a hole right
through visions chests and rips out his
insides killing him instantly next to
die is Iron Man
when Scarlet Witch was killed iron man
begins to attack Thanos but Danos had
created a perfect woman for him named
Tareq Zia and Tareq Zia tackles him out
of midair while he's attacking Thanos
she then throws him on the ground and
proceeds to kill him by ripping off his
head once iron man dies spider-man
swings in and kick Stannis in the face
yelling at Thor that he'll killed her
Axia while thor takes on Thanos not a
good call by spotty custer axia
instantly jumps on top of him and then
proceeds to kill him by beating him to
death with a rock while spider-man is
being beaten to death
Thor lays down the hammer on Thanos
unfortunately the Infinity Gauntlet is
too strong and Thanos uses it to turn
Thor into glass once Thor's turned into
glass Diana smashes his fist through him
completely shattering him and killing
instantly the last of the Avengers to
stand is our hero Captain America
walking up to Thanos saying it's not
over to the fat lady sings as Captain
America and Thanos walk towards each
other the Silver Surfer waits on the
sidelines getting ready to attack Thanos
to try and steal the Infinity Gauntlet
from him once Captain America gets to
Thanos he tells him as long as one man
stands against you Thanos you'll never
be able to claim victory
danos replies by saying that's a noble
sentiment from one who was about to die
Captain America tells Thanos they're
well worth dying for and the fight
begins
Thanos then uses the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet to make hands come out
of the ground and grab Captain America's
feet then he yells at him then you shall
die
Thanos then strikes Captain America
shield shattering it into pieces saying
vanos is always pleased to honor such a
foolish request right as Thanos is about
to strike Captain America to kill him
the Silver Surfer attacks
unfortunately the Silver Surfer misses
and then Thanos proceeds to kill Captain
America by backhanding him to the face
from this point on the only people that
are left are the Silver Surfer and Adam
warlock and dr. strange who's
technically still on earth but I just
want to point out that the silver
surfers character appeared on the
characters list on IMDB before it was
taken down and we've already been
introduced to Adam warlocks cocoon at
the end of guardians of the galaxy vol 2
I know it's been stated that Adam
warlock won't make an appearance until
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but I
think this may just be a trick from
Marvel to try to throw us off and not
really know what's going to happen in
Avengers infinity war or Avengers 4 I
would really love for them both to make
an appearance they're two awesome
characters although I don't think it's
likely but there's a chance so you're
telling me there's a chance yeah so this
is it for all the Avengers that died in
the Infinity Gauntlet comic series what
do you guys think about how these
characters die and do you think they'll
bring any of this from the comics into
the movies also seeing how strong
Stannis is do you think our Avengers
even stand a chance against him let me
know your thoughts and theories and then
comments section below and if you
enjoyed this video please be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to my
channel for more videos on the Avenger
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching
woof woof there was an idea to bring
together a group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles they never could